did you know that the stomach if you
just think about it can slice itself
open did you know that did you know that
you can just cut your whole stomach with
your mind and bleed really yeah they're
like a little Wolverine living in your
stomach do you know what it's called
what's it called it's called a [__]
ulcer no this is a real then we go oh oh
yeah yeah no no I have them yeah but
that's what I'm saying it's stress
you're my if your mind can change your
body yeah the mind can change the world
around yeah you can perforate yourself
oh my God
honestly honestly I really needed to
hear this to be honest with you just now
I really did because I mean this last
month have been tough for me and um you
know I've been trying to spend this last
month into a positive here's the one
thing I know about myself
um I'm a Survivor I'm strong I'm
stronger than I think I am oh yeah and
um I have so many people that love me
and these are all the things I really do
like I um
I mean I love you George oh
wow he really has a hard time getting an
ulcer he's getting an ulcer oh [__] [__]
his stomach's cutting oh
oh that was hard
oh my God I said it I love you how often
do you say those nice things about
yourself
never see I say them I say them often
people think uh they they mistake that
for uh Cockiness yeah it's necessary it
genuinely is necessary and I will say
this like all of my medical ailments
like I have a heart condition that I got
a procedure on a couple years ago I have
a lot of like like
ulcer GI stuff and it's not hereditary
no one in my family has this so I know
that it's just like life and like like
repressed stuff sort of like making its
way and like Perforating my own like
slicing my own stomach open at that I
absolutely believe and I think I've been
doing that for most of my life why it's
cut well it's just you know like before
I my like address my trauma before I
address all the sexual stuff yeah like
that's just that's the stuff lives in
your body and if you don't do anything
about it if you just try to White
Knuckle through it like that's what
happens you will perforate your therapy
is everything I learned that yeah oh it
saved my life same saved my [__] life
like but then it's like such an ongoing
Journey too because you think oh I'm
therapized I've learned enough I'm able
to intellectually
it never [__] ends but that's life
it's the game of life you know a lot of
people they they want to know the
meaning of life I think it's just to
live it I know that's my son whatever
but I really instead of trying to figure
it all out I say man just enjoy the ride
while you can you know so I think it's
really beautiful that you've come to
this uh realization with yourself to be
nice to yourself and to love yourself
and to say good job I'll tell you man
every once in a while I'd say I'd say
about at least once a week I try to look
in the mirror and tell myself I love
myself and Pat myself on the back and go
good job okay let's try that right now
with you Bobby what I've been doing last
night
the one thing I did also just the last
couple weeks that I've never done before
is I was at your house and I was laying
on the couch I was in a bad State and I
laid on the couch and I went you know I
love you dude to myself oh my God I
think I took a picture of that moment
yeah and I said um I'm so sorry you're
going through this
you know I took a picture and I started
weeping what what is it what I mean what
was it that you were going through I'll
tell you later okay I said I would never
talk about that understood you know
what's so crazy is that he was on my
couch and I remember looking at him and
thinking I have never seen this man like
this before and so I was like
click so I just wanted to have like a
mental picture of like so he kind of
knows like the state that he was in and
he was his back he was like kind of
hugging the he you know the back of the
couch his face was like smushed against
it like he was either trying to like
Escape reality
dog goby was like on on his her side
looking at me like you're like hey you
know what I mean and I went I went I
said that to myself like I'm so sorry
and then I looked at goby and I went
oh this this creature loves me yeah
unconditionally I mean it was like this
weird kind of connection I had with this
little tiny my little daughter you know
what I mean and and uh and it just her
eyes were glistening and she was so
happy to see me because you know we
raised Gobi and then they moved right so
I have the cats and she has the dog so
you guys were married right no we were
dating dating yeah so the dogs you know
I mean are they don't know English
so they don't know what happened you
know what I mean let's say I'm sure they
could comprehend it but we don't know
their language you know what I mean
because they don't know what's going on
when they see me they're so happy to see
me wow yeah I mean anyway
um
yeah I know I've um I'm really kind of
proud of myself anyway I don't talk
about myself no you should you should
talk about yourself I mean you do and
like even when you when people are
paying you compliments giving you your
flowers you really have a hard time
receiving I do I I do
I can still be that way but it was
really bad before
and then you just gotta be like hell
yeah I'm the [__] you know what I mean
like you really just got to be like [__]
yeah as long as you're not treating
people with such said arrogant you know
well not arrogance but confidence like
there's just there's just a a way to go
about it you know what I mean it's like
and I don't think there's really a wrong
like if you look at Kanye like on his
come up and everything like he was
saying he was the greatest because he
had nobody else there to tell him that
you know what I mean like he was like no
I am the I am the [__] I am the this or
whatever and I feel like
every great creative has to do that
because we all feel like frauds I think
there's a part deep down that's like why
am I here or what why did I do or did it
or this is all fake they're going to
find out I don't know what it is and
I've talked to a lot of other creatives
and they just feel that way they feel
like
I'm a pioneer of that there you go
I was the first guy Asian guy to do it
all I I did it yeah baby oh I did it
when it they didn't want us I mean you
can see Ali and all these people Stephen
you know that's I'm so happy for them
yeah yeah they're killing it but I did
it when they were like no you don't
We're Not Gonna hire you wow and I may I
did it that's how I feel about it like I
I did all kinds of [__] right that was
the first you know what I mean and it's
like um any of these young kids like
Aquafina and all these people they come
up to him and they tell me and I never
used to believe it you know be like oh
my God we look out for you we thank you
so much and this and that and it's a
site but I do believe it now so um man
it feels weird to say but it's good yeah
I'm Neil Armstrong
[Laughter]
I'm Neil Armstrong Asian style
is your um podcast going to be guest
driven yeah all right so you're going to
do it in Portland no I'm gonna do in LA
that's why I'm here all right I'm here
just kidding well I mean I would love to
do it oh really yeah we could no well
maybe we'll pencil you in that's a joke
of course it's ridiculous you would say
something because
um you know are you serious I would love
to have